hi there Steve Kaufman here first of all
if you like these videos about language
learning please subscribe to my channel
and also let me know if there's anything
you want me to talk about in particular
today I'm gonna talk about the
revolution in language learning of the
21st century before I do that I want to
say that I generally make my videos in
English I try to speak slowly and
clearly
so that people whose first language is
not English have a chance of
understanding me and then we make a
transcript of the video available at
link as a lesson where you can study the
text listen to the audio pick up any
words and phrases that you might have
missed and I think this way I reach the
broadest possible audience I am prepared
however to have conversations with any
of you who are native speakers of other
languages languages that I speak there's
about 15 of them
I might have to prepare for some of them
but I'm very happy to have conversations
on not just on language learning but
perhaps primarily on language learning
but the revolution in line was running
when I studied Chinese back in 1968 I
had a big open reel tape recorder that
sat in my room and if I wanted to listen
I had to listen they're sitting down
today I have my iPod Nano for when I am
exercising washing the dishes when I'm
very mobile this light blue iPod nano
nano has more audio in it than the
average language lab would have had back
50 years ago and it's all things of
interest to me on my iPhone I can take I
have the same audio as on my Nano but
this way if I'm sitting in the car
driving Bluetooth I can sync it to my
car speakers if there's a phone call I
can also pick up the phone call again
hands-free etcetera etc and I in the
meantime
and listen to my audio I can also
download audiobooks from audible.com and
have them all stored in here to listen
to I can also do link on my iPhone
although if I have the opportunity I
prefer to do it on my iPad so these
three tools are just phenomenal in terms
of making language learning more
efficient more comfortable easier now
fifty years ago my main activity in
order to you know improve my Chinese was
listening and reading I didn't know I
had never heard of Stephen crashing but
everything that stephen krashen says
about language acquisition through input
was exactly how I went about it I was
aware as a learner of Chinese I became
aware very early of the importance of
efficiency because other than your
attitude your motivation your confidence
the next most important factor is time
so if you can double the efficiency or
triple the efficiency of your
utilization of study time you know that
doesn't just double or triple your speed
of learning
I felt it geometrically increased my
speed of learning so very early I
decided I am NOT going to flip through a
dictionary because I forget the meaning
as soon as I closed the dictionary and
particularly with learning Chinese it
was very time consuming to look words up
in a dictionary
I looked for readers on a variety of
subjects which had glossaries the
inconvenience of the glossary obviously
is that the glossary can't anticipate
which words you know and don't know so
very often the words you want to find a
meaning for aren't there conversely
words that you know are in the glossary
list plus is distracting to flip back
and forth so the first major revolution
was the mp3 file initially the minidisc
mp3 fly files mp3 players the audio the
transport ability portability of audio
the second thing is the online
dictionary so you can be reading online
and immediately see the meaning
of course you can do things the way we
do at linked with these words and
phrases that you look up if it save them
you can review them you can do so many
things on a device like the iPhone or
the iPad that text comes alive and all
of that makes the learning much more
efficient granted it's more comfortable
to read a book but I find that until I
have a sufficient vocabulary level it's
frustrating to always come across words
that I don't know and of course look
them up in a dictionary forget the
meaning write out a bunch of lists
longhand that I never look at so the
availability of online dictionaries has
made it possible to access texts that
are perhaps too difficult but because
they are interesting they're ideal
learning material so again I want to
give credit and the third thing I want
to give credit to stephen krashen I
totally agree with what he says about
the importance of input eventually you
have to speak and when you speak you're
you're involved with the language you're
fighting you're trying to express
yourself it become very real the
resonance is very high but before you
get into the ring and to wrestle or to
box with the language you have to have
some weapons you have to be able to
understand what the other person is
saying you have to have some words to
defend yourself with and that's where
the importance of input based learning
comes in and I tell you when I wrote my
book about language learning this was
the book and we also translated into
Chinese was published in China I mean
all the things that I said there were
pure crashing before I heard of crashing
but crashing explains it so elegantly
he explains and he backs it up with
research and so if we couple what we now
know about the importance of input based
learning with the tools that are now
available to make language learning so
much more efficient and so much more
convenient that net effect plus the
availability of the internet and all the
resources that are there the net effect
is a
pollution a revolution not only in terms
of input based learning based learning
but eventually even in terms of talking
to people and communicating with people
it's a wonderful world the 21st century
and I should say that we often hear a
lot of negativity about the world today
I am such an optimist I feel it's a
wonderful time to be alive yes there are
problems in the Middle East problems in
in Ukraine problems of in Africa and
wherever there are always problems there
are wheels will be problems but there
always were problems but in terms of the
improvement of living standards for a
vast majority of people in the world the
number of people have been taken out of
poverty what we're now seeing in terms
of the reducing price or cost of solar
and wind power the ability of humans to
come up with technical solutions for the
problems that we have not the least of
which is technical improvements in the
learning of languages I am an optimist
and I think to be a language learner I
think it helps to be an optimist because
you have to believe that you can do it
you have to believe that it's worthwhile
you have to believe that the method
you're using is gonna take you to where
you want to get to in terms of achieving
fluency so a bit of a ramble today but I
do believe the 21st century is
revolutionary when it comes to language
learning we should be aware of it
we should take advantage of it kids in
school shouldn't just learn one language
they should learn two languages and
discover more of the world and it's now
easier to do than it ever was so thanks
for listening
a bit of a long ramble bye for now
you